not long after the last leadership
contest ended bets are now being taken
on who will fill the old new prime
minister's shoes in the frame to replace
Liz truss who resigned after just six
weeks his former Chancellor Rishi sunak
leader of the commons Penny mordant and
a certain Boris Johnson
I think it's pretty chaotic I think the
conservatives
are more interested in their own
personal gain than they are in what's
right for the country as they're saying
that Boris Johnson is going to run again
it just still looks a bit silly did it
tonight I mean everyone's saying bring
Boris back aren't they you know speak to
everyone you see it on the news bring
boy respect so let's bring him back the
man who resigned in July after one
Scandal too many is now Gathering
support for a push to regain number 10.
Johnson is still being investigated on
accusations he lied to Parliament about
parties he attended during covid-19
lockdowns if he does run he'll need to
persuade at least a hundred fellow MPS
to support him but his appeal among
voters could help him sway those of his
colleagues who doubt his moral
credentials Hey listen will be our
potentially our third prime minister
since the general election of 2019 that
means we have to think about that
legitimacy question that the public will
be asking themselves and also about who
could win the next election that's
obviously important for any political
party at the time so you know at the
moment I would lean towards Boris
Johnson I think he will still have some
questions to answer around obviously
that investigation the crisis at
Westminster may be embarrassing for the
conservatives and for Britain for others
the government's economic mismanagement
has more serious consequences
a short walk from Parliament this
community center provides meals for an
increasing number of people who are
struggling the volunteers feel the
government's infighting is making
matters worse I have seen so much in the
last few weeks by nowhere near have we
seen the brunt of this storm that's
coming people with working jobs aren't
able to make any Smee anymore the
government needs to look at what's
happening on the front line and they're
not
mordant was the first to officially
declare her candidacy on Friday she
might hope those who can stomach neither
sunach nor Johnson will choose her as a
unifying candidate in a party leadership
vote that's due to take place next week
the Fallout from Liz truss's brief time
in office has left deep divisions in a
government and party whose Unity was
already falling apart conservative MPS
may spend the coming days deciding
whether they want to vote another new
face into office or go back to one they
know Boris Johnson
Polaris Al Jazeera London